[Music]
hi folks sorry about the delay my name
is Jeff Mayer I'm a senior data
scientist at guru and today I will be
talking to you about empowering people
on customer facing teams with a little
bit of ml so first what is guru at guru
we believe that the knowledge you need
to do your job should find you and that
piece find you is really important all
right it's really the opposite of how
people typically look for information
and this is where the machine learning
aspect comes in and the reality is that
in today's world knowledge workers spend
a lot of their time moving between many
different applications just to be able
to find the information that they need
to accomplish their task so if you think
of you know your average startup not
even the big company you have
information that might live in Dropbox
in Google suit and Google a Google suite
Google Docs Google Spreadsheets there
might be information in Salesforce in
intercom in Zendesk in slack it's really
spread all over the place and when
people think about knowledge management
they usually think of confluence they
think of wiki sites and it becomes very
hard to know where to look for that
information and even when you find it
you don't know if you can still trust it
right you look at that conference
article you see that it was written six
months ago or a year ago and you have no
idea if it's still relevant if you can
trust that information and so this is
where guru comes in just to give you a
little bit more perspective on this
Microsoft recently did a study where
they actually looked at how people work
this is three years old right so things
like slack and Microsoft teams in some
sense are exacerbating this as well but
what Microsoft found is that information
workers on average switch windows 373
times a day or around every 40 seconds
right and you can imagine what kind of
effects that has on them multitasking on
them being able to
to complete tasks it's just it is
information overload people are getting
distracted they're switching context all
the time and so this actually causes a
lot of frustration and so at guru we
believe that there is a different way to
do this and again the mission is that
the knowledge into the new job should
find you and we use ml to support that
mission and so what guru does is Guru
gathers your company's knowledge from
all the different sources where that
information might reside so think
experts right a lot of time very
important information is literally in
the head of the people who are working
at your company and so experts can
create the pieces of knowledge we also
get that knowledge from documents that
might be in Google suite and Dropbox in
other places and also from a variety of
applications so if you're on the support
team and you're working in intercom if
you have a ticketing solution we can get
that information in as well and so we
get that information we unified into a
single source of truth and then using
machine learning guru surfaces that
knowledge to you in your favorite work
application and so we integrate with a
number of applications here just a few
of them slack intercoms and ask
Salesforce if you're on the sales team
Gmail etc here are just a few of the
machine learning features we have in
production and the goal is to not only
surface knowledge to folks in real time
but also take management out of
knowledge management right one of the
reasons knowledge management
historically has failed is because it is
a real burden to maintain a knowledge
base right you do have to manage some
companies have dedicated people to just
that aspect of knowledge management and
so we have a variety of features in
production this is just the selection of
them but for the purposes of today's
talk I'm going to focus on a I suggest
voice and the idea behind a I suggest
voice is that we would like to suggest
knowledge in real time in phone
conversations and conference calls right
so a lot of modern-day teams spend quite
a bit of their time in meetings in
conference calls how can we facilitate
these meetings facilitate these
conversations
just to make this a little bit more
concrete here we have Megan listening to
being on a conversation on a call and so
what we'd like to do is we would like to
listen to audio of the conversation we
would like to be able to transcribe
speech to text to see what is happening
in a conversation and we would like to
recommend relevant contextual knowledge
to Megan so that she you know can
experience this aha moment and when a
customer asks a particularly tricky
question
she knows how to navigate a conversation
instead of saying you know what this is
a really good question let me get back
to you and what happens a lot of the
time people forget to follow up right or
it just generally leads to a bad
customer experience so let's dive into
it I suggest voice I'm gonna show a very
brief demo which is just a gif but what
I wanted to show is on the left you see
that the Guru is listening to that
conversation in the top right corner we
have people on a conference call they're
talking to each other and we're
listening to the conversation we are
transcribing the conversation in real
time and we're surfacing relevant pieces
of information and so what you see there
are titles of cards from the knowledge
base that are relevant to that
interaction and on the right hand side
you will see when a person clicks in
they're able to see the content of the
card and you will also be able to see
the transcription itself and so here's
the Guru system's listening somebody's
asking I'm Chinese analytics but the
group list isn't appearing and so there
is a card that is relevant and is
explaining how to navigate that
situation and as the conversation
progresses you know it goes into
discussion of collections and how to
properly set them up we bring relevant
cards so that the agent can talk to the
customer and navigate their questions
and so I hope this gives you a more
concrete sense of what we're trying to
do and it turns out this is a very hard
problem to solve and to end
and there are several reasons for this
so what I showed on the previous slide
this is at this instance a desktop
application so this could be on your Mac
machine this could be on Windows and on
the client side the problem is hard
because you want to first be able to
capture audio for both parties and two
parties is really the simplest case in
all of this right there are a lot of
meetings where you have quite a few
participants and so you want to
faithfully capture that audio and you
want to be able to stream it in real
time you want to be able to support a
variety of operating systems and
hardware and you also want to create a
user experience that does not distract
right the last thing we want to do is be
is is distract the person from the
conversation they're having so we really
want in that sense yes it just always to
be that little whisper in your ears like
hey there is something relevant here and
so the reason I bring this up is that it
has really important implications for
the data science side of it all right
what can we actually capture what kind
of information what kind of interactions
what can we show to the user and so this
becomes really important when we start
thinking about building ml on top of
this data now that's just the client
side on the data science side
fundamentally we want to a high level
transcribe speech and suggest knowledge
and we want to do both of these things
in real time right as the conversation
is progressing so this is very difficult
we also want to be able to handle speech
detection we're not necessarily
interested in everything that is
happening right there could be a lot of
silence there could be clapping we're
really interested just in speech in the
information hasn't that meeting you have
to be cognizant of multiple speakers
being present in the room or on the call
right so how do you handle speaker
separation and noise right noise that
could be back music playing in the
background it could be raining outside
if somebody could be having conversation
in the adjacent room and so all of this
makes it a challenging environment and
then you also want to take us the
jørgen to account right if we're talking
about Shopify or Spotify right they use
very different lingo to talk about their
products right and that's not even part
of the regular English language
necessarily how do we take that custom
jargon into account to be able to
transcribe things well and suggest
knowledge on the infrastructure side we
want to have a scalable infrastructure
for streaming model training and serving
and we really want to embrace customer
diversity right so every customer is
different the nice thing about guru is
that it is a vertical agnostic solution
so it doesn't matter whether you're in
the e-commerce space if you are in the
music space if you're manufacturing cars
right everybody has a knowledge
management problem and every team has a
knowledge management problem and so with
that in mind you want to embrace the
diversity and you do want to serve
multiple models supporting all of the
above in production and when it comes to
transcribing speech specifically you
want to make it cost effective right if
we think about current providers out
there are there really only three
companies who do that there is Amazon
there is Microsoft and there is Google
and the reason they're able to offer
speech-to-text api's is because they
have invested invested decades of labour
and money to collect the data to be able
to build models to transcribe
speech-to-text of course that comes at a
price because they did invest a lot of
time and effort into it and so these
services are prohibitively expensive so
if you're trying to do this at scale if
you're trying to support thousands of
agents for a particular customer right
this is not this is not a viable
solution so we're driven through this
for financial reasons we are startup but
the added benefit is that you can
actually instead of working with a
general solution that a Google or AWS or
Asia API is we can build a specialized
model that is built for very specific
purpose and very specific use case
and then the last but probably the most
important is the challenge I'll already
alluded to is how do you get data for
training the model to be able to
transcribe speech to text so here's a
high-level architecture of a I suggest
voice and we have a voice client that is
streaming audio data to us to the data
science side so the goop guru streaming
speech to knowledge API when we started
working on this we were very lucky in
that Amazon actually rolled out API yet
gateway WebSocket right and so what that
meant for us is that we didn't have to
worry about scaling to thousands of
persistent connections all right this is
something that could be essentially done
for us and we're using a streaming API
so there's very little overhead we just
send in the information that we need and
because we wanted to keep things quite
cost-effective we designed this whole
architecture using a several or
serverless framework and so after the
data arrives the web socket API we have
an authentication service that is
powered by lamda and we're also sending
audio frames to our speech to knowledge
service right and the job of the speech
knowledge service is to aggregate audio
frames that are coming in through the
WebSocket right and we then have to
stitch all these audio frames to get
actual audio segments we would like to
persist the session the voice session to
s 3 and then speech the knowledge
service orchestrates the rest of the
work that needs to be done and so it
uses the Guru inference API to call
speech to text that we will dive into a
little bit more and the job of the
speech-to-text service is to transcribe
the audio being sent by the speech
knowledge service speech the text is
built on top of ECS it is using models
that have been pre trained so we have
models and features in s3 and
once the speech-to-text service
transcribes and utterance right we want
to actually accumulate utterances in a
conversation before suggesting knowledge
and so speech the knowledge service that
makes request to the text the knowledge
service so that we can surface relevant
information to the user in real time and
so again all of this hat has to happen
in as close to real time as possible so
let's dive in a little bit more into
speech to text specifically and so nice
thing about doing this in 2018 and 2019
is that you know we're not starting from
scratch we're literally standing on the
shoulders of giants what I'm showing
here is paper published by by do
research so literally Giants were
dealing with e-commerce giant and we're
also dealing with giant of the data
science community Andrew Young is one of
the co-authors on this paper and what is
unique about this paper is not that it
is using deep learning neural Nets have
actually been applied to speech
recognition for over 20 years what is
unique about this paper is that prior to
it there was really no true and to end
deep learning solution so people would
use neural nets in various parts of
their speech recognition service but
they would still have to hand engineer a
lot of features and B to be able to take
care of things like noise and
reverberation and aligning audio frames
to the transcription people were using
hidden Markov models so traditional
systems employ very heavily engineered
processing stages and by this was really
one of the first demonstrations that you
can apply deep learning and to end and
you can predict sequences of characters
from input audio they followed up with
another paper called deep speech - where
they explored various architectures so
sort of a deeper analysis on what
could be done and to end and I really
wanted to give credit to by do because
by publishing these results which is
also you can the industry right when we
look at what Google is doing or what
Amazon is doing it's actually really
hard to find detailed descriptions of
what is being done and so I really want
to give them credit for publishing this
because the publication of this led to
democratizing speech research in the
community and so as an example one of
the companies that has been building on
top of this is Mozilla they were
inspired to for the contribute to this
research and so we're standing on the
shoulders above these giants and we're
building on top of what has been done
before us and so here's the approach at
a high level so given an utterance X of
T so this is just a function in time
right this could be an amplitude in time
we would like to generate a
transcription sequence Y hat of Y hat
and so every every member of that
sequence Y hat of tau right is a letter
let's say in the English alphabet A
through Z and we also add a space here
so tau here denotes the index within the
sequence and just to make things a
little bit more concrete so on the
bottom you see this function X of T it's
an amplitude waveform in time the goal
is for us to go from that representation
to the text above and here what we're
saying is the knowledge in you to do
your job should find you and just to
clarify the notation I here is an
utterance right and utterance in our
training data cell for example we could
have an utterances and so the general
approach that we take is that we train a
neural network that would allow us to
extract Y hat from the final layer of
that network and this becomes our
acoustic model and what we do is we use
a recurrent neural net the reason we do
that is because recurrent neural Nets
are really good sequence learners right
so when you're trying to transcribe
speech you actually do want to see what
happened before potentially what
happened
after as well in that audio and because
there's such powerful sequence learners
we can effectively incorporate the state
where where the speaker is in order to
be able to predict what is being said as
features what we use for this RNN is a
sequence of log spectrograms so we take
that initial audio input that is
function of time and we convert into the
spectral domain and basically what we do
is we take fast Fourier transform every
20 milliseconds and we end up with the
sequence of these log spectrograms and
then we have a few layers in the
network's and so the first three layers
are non recurrent they're fully
connected and the idea is to take the
neighboring context see into account so
when we look at that spectrogram we look
at a context that at any given point in
time we do want to see what is happening
in the neighborhood of that specific
point in time and on the fourth layer is
our recurrent layer the difference
between what Baidu did and what we're
doing is that Baidu employ the be
directional approach we're using a
unidirectional approach the reason we're
doing this is because in a be
directional approach you want to go
forward and you want to go back which
means that the output at any given time
depends on future input right and that's
a challenge for us because we're trying
to transcribe in real time
so as we're transcribing in real time we
want to make sure that the output the
transcription at this point in time
depends only on things that we have seen
in the past and then the fifth layer is
a standard softmax layer you essentially
have a bank of neurons that are
representing characters in your alphabet
right and we want to be able to read out
the output of that bank to see what kind
of character are we predicting so this
is just at a high level things get a
whole lot trickier once you actually
start training this thing because it is
a challenging problem to be able to
match up the audio frames and the
transcription right so in this example
what is what is being boys is the word
guru
but there are many different ways in
which I can say group right I could say
guru I could say guru I could say guru
right how do you you you basically end
up with a variable length input but a
fixed length output and it's a
fundamental challenge in speech
recognition and so the approach we
employ is we use a connection connection
is temporal classifications so this is a
paper that was published back in 2006 by
graves at all and the idea there is you
actually want to enforce the length of
the input and the length of the output
being the same and the way you do that
is that you say you know the fifth layer
really encodes a probability of seeing a
particular character given the input X
and you do that over sorry I increase
the probability of seeing a particular
character sequence given the input X
where the length of the character
sequence is really the same as the
length of the input and one trick that
you do here is you add a blank label
essentially right because when you look
at audio you're not necessarily
pronouncing thanks and so in this gap in
this example when we say guru right in
the beginning there is nothing right so
we say there's a blank and then we start
predicting what kind of character is
present in that context that in that
window of context and so you could see
characters being repeated right that's
why you see GG uu and what you can do is
you can define a many to one map B and
the reason it's a many to one map is
because there are many different paths
many different ways to get to guru so
what I'm showing as a character sequence
above could really be you know one
character G in the beginning and
followed by two characters you it all
depends on how fast you say that even
for the same audio sequence you could
potentially transcribe it differently
depending on the speaker and so what you
end up is really with many paths to get
to the same transcription and so what
you want to do is define a many to one
taking these many different paths to the
transcription text guru and one way to
think about this map bee is that it's
essentially a squeeze operator that
looks at these duplicate characters gets
rid of them also gets rid of blanks and
what's really cool is the graves at all
Sheol
showed that there is a very efficient
way using dynamic programming to compute
this probability of seeing transcription
why given input X just by summing over
all of these different hats and
furthermore you can calculate the
gradient of this and which means you can
use back propagation to compute optimal
parameters for this network so you can
solve this maximum likelihood function
and update the parameters theta now
things are so you could say okay we've
trained this is great how do we actually
do inference the inference itself is
actually tricky because in training we
do have the labels right so we're able
to calculate all these probabilities
efficiently at inference it is very hard
to be able to say this is the most
likely sequence in fact there is no
tractable way of doing this and you have
to employ search to be able to find the
best the most probable transcription and
so there's several ways of going about
this you can simply use max decoding via
the same operator B you can also use
graphics decoding that was proposed in
that same paper but I graves at all
however even with the best decoding what
ends up happening is that you see
spelling and linguistic errors an
intuitive way to understand this is
something is called the Tchaikovsky
problem in the literature it's that if
you haven't seen how to spell
Tchaikovsky before what the neural
network is going to try to do it's going
to try to transcribe this the best of
its ability right so it might put a w
instead of a V if I miss a C between the
T and the H and so it really depends on
what data you see what audio data you
use to trained us what kind of labels
you have available to you
and so we are quite limited when it
comes to audio data right we have
something much bigger at our disposal
and so typically what you want to try to
do is actually introduce a language
model into this and the idea behind
language model is that it actually
captures the probabilities inherent in
the language right so when we think
about an English language if I say the
word pause right you wouldn't
necessarily know if that means a pause
in a sentence or if it means an animal's
pause right so we can use language model
to effectively take that context into
account what we use is an Engram model
called kennel M that is available that
is trained on publicly available corpora
but this is essentially a plug-and-play
situation because you could also be
using other language models or it's a
bird for example is one of the things
that is has been on the news recently
and we can quickly look up words via
beam search so one of the nice things
about Engram models is that you can
actually very quickly look things up but
most importantly you can quickly update
these models so you can update with new
or newly important words for that
particular context or that particular
task and just to give an example this is
from the original paper in graves at all
what you see on the left is the RN and
output without the language model right
so it hasn't seen a lot of instances of
Boston and so it says what is the
weather like in Boston right now right
it doesn't know that it should be Boston
spelled with a letter O because there
were probably a few examples of that in
the training set so this is this is the
the main idea behind text-to-speech and
when it comes to the text knowledge
service we actually reusing some we're
using a micro service already president
guru so this is different scenario where
we are suggesting knowledge based on the
text that people see so this could be in
a chat this could be in a support ticket
this could be in email where we already
have think of it as transcribed speech
to us trance
Veta and so the idea here is to suggest
the most relevant piece of knowledge or
the most the most relevant set of
knowledge to to the agent and so a
high-level what we want to do is offline
we would like to run an LP pipeline to
extract features from individual pieces
of knowledge in guru we call these cards
these are bite-sized pieces of
information that a user can process very
quickly and then we want embed each card
in a multi-dimensional space and then
what we do is we use these features
along with event beta being generated by
our users to train a weekly supervised
recommender system and the reason it's
weekly supervised is because not only
interactions necessarily guarantee that
that particular card or set of cards
were using a conversations right if
somebody viewed a card
it may have been useful maybe not so in
other words the labels are noisy but
this is a good thing
there were several talks talking about
the advantages of that because you can
collect a whole lot more data right and
you can you can train a faculty on this
and so this is the offline portion and
then online what we want to do is we
want to process newly observed text so
in the I suggest voice this would be a
freshly transcribed utterance and we
want to use the same NLP pipeline and we
want to suggest tap K cards so just to
quickly recap all of this our mission is
that the knowledge you need to do your
job should find you when it comes to a I
suggest voice what we mean is that we
want to apply that mission to voice and
this is really hard problem to solve and
to end however it is doable given recent
advances in end to end deep learning for
speech recognition and if you use a
recurrent neural net with connections
temporal classification and a language
model this actually works quite well and
then the speech the knowledge service
for us is comprised essentially a high
level of two things speech to text and
text the knowledge service and I wanted
to dive into some of the lessons learned
because again this this was and still is
a hard problem we're learning a lot and
we iterating on this but among the
lessons learned is that quality data is
key
the biggest challenge really is on the
transcription side it's having access to
audio data for training right again this
is one of the reasons why only companies
like AWS and GCP and Asia are actually
able to do this and offer this as a
service but they're surely charging a
very nice premium for that and to put
things in context Baidu's network was
trained on more than 10,000 hours of
audio right so for any company being
able to generate 10,000 hours of audio
is a daunting proposition and Mozilla
again was one of the companies that
realized that access to such data will
fundamentally allow for broad innovation
in this space and actually started
something called a common voice
initiative and so you can go to the
common voice project online please do
the whole idea behind it is that you can
contribute to this effort
you can contribute not only your own
voice but you can also help transcribe
speech you can help transcribe
utterances and what's really cool is
that they're building this open-source
multi-language data set and so when you
look at it they're actually there's
audio data available in a variety of
languages and this data set is growing
in time
that being said even if you look at this
right so at the moment there are only
700 validated hours right so it's really
at an early stage it will definitely
grow and so you have to be clever and
you have to use other sources so you
have to use other public datasets
you can also synthesize data right so if
you are looking to address issues with
noise for example right noise is
something that you can synthesize to a
certain extent right you can record that
rain outside right you can record a
conversation in the hall in a coffee
shop right and you can start
superimposing different pieces of audio
to generate noise and when it comes to
language model quality data matters as
well all right one of the things we
mentioned language model does is it
incorporates probabilities inherently
present in the language to be able to
transcribe more effectively and correct
for some of the phishing
is the problem is that if you are trying
to train this on publicly available data
right
what kind of publicly available data is
available to us there are a lot of
audiobooks or just plain books and when
it comes to copyright if you want to be
able to use this this effectively means
older books right so this is older
English not necessarily spoken English
not in formal English or any other in
the formal language and so you have to
be careful there as well if you're
trying to transcribe what is being said
in the formal conversation that becomes
a real issue as well among other lessons
learned there really a lot of a lot of
details that need to be figured out even
as as simple as audio packets arriving
out of order right things happen you
need to make sure that things actually
do arrive in order and you need to
correct for that transcriptions could be
generated out of order right it does
take longer to transcribe a longer
utterance and so if you send off that
longer utterance first followed by
something shorter transcription resolve
for the shorter utterance might come
back first so you need to do a good job
keeping track of all of this when it
comes to voice activity detection to be
able to detect when there is speech
again because we're trying to do this in
a cost-effective fashion doing
serverless voice activity detection is
actually a real challenge as a state of
the art models usually have some sort of
hidden state to them right and becomes a
challenge essentially sharing that state
in a serverless environment and Grahm
language models are quite large
right so again if you're talking about
having multiple language models in
production you need to think very
carefully about how you're going to
scale this they were just scalability
lessons galore in all of this and then
probably the most important challenge is
being greedy so we are a small team but
we have grit and no presentations
complete without a gift and since we are
based in Philly here's a gif of gritty
who is the mascot of the Philadelphia
Flyers and
most important slide is everything
discussed above is a fruit of many
people's labor guru a lot of smart
people put quite a bit of effort into
all of this some of us are present here
in the audience today this is the
product data science team come say hi
and stop by our booth thank you and I'll
take questions that's a great question
yes and that that's one of the reasons
why again companies like Amazon and
Google and Microsoft have invested so
many years of effort into this Amazon
was actually really smart about him
about putting Alexa into every single
person's home and what do they get with
that they get a variety of accents and
ways to pronounce the exact same thing
and so yes you have to pay attention to
that and you have to make sure that your
data is is representative and it's very
much an iterative task and something you
could be improving for a long time
[Music]